all right justin
yeah justin uh where'd you grow up where
are you from originally where
you're from texas yeah
dallas and tell me about your childhood
you had both your parents when you were
a kid
of going to people for four years i'm
sorry can i ask you to speak up a little
bit
kind of go my groove off and trouble
with you
i'm sorry i can barely hear you because
you've also told your parents
we're having a hard time doing this
because because you're kind of mumbling
my parents weren't really there when i
was growing up oh they weren't
no where were your parents the seas
they died early yeah how did you how did
your parents pass away
i was out of cancer
you did what yeah
he was never around no so who raised you
i got my group out for several years
did you ever have any
anyone you could call like a parent oh
really
how would you describe your childhood
i don't know everything
i'm sorry i'm just scrolling everything
i guess it was all right
did you do you have any way you consider
to be your parents
not really not just alive you know
how far did you go in school i'm a gg
19.
two years in prison time yeah i did like
12 and a quarter years i was getting my
students challenging
what did you do when you went out on
your own
you have jobs i used to work a lot even
on the streets
but i used to excuse me but i don't
recognize your
respiratory justin i can barely
understand you when you mumble
well i used to work alive and not you
know i'm trying to get back on my social
security [ __ ]
and do you have children of your own no
i had a certificate
when i was 19. i'm sorry i had a certain
person was absolutely
nice you had a son that was put up for
adoption when you were 19.
were you married once
you ever been in love i need somebody
once or twice
do you feel like you were ever loved by
your by
anyone in your mouth you don't really
have family do you
do you ever feel like you've been loved
no this is by myself yeah
so now today you're here on skid row
hey what what uh
[Music]
what is your drug today or is it alcohol
that
i i i remember
from having back my feet i'm sorry
do you like christmas
[Music]
it's my feeding drink drink yeah
how much do you drink a day i'd say this
is a cowboy day or something
sorry and you
want to choose or subway everything
so that's kind of good tall boys is that
what you're saying yeah
uh i'm sorry
so now sometimes they keep victory like
[Music]
where do you stay at night where do you
sleep as we go around we need to sleep i
wanted some bushes behind some bushes
[Music]
yeah
people leave you alone or do you get you
get hassled sometimes
i don't even bother when i'm sleeping
she got kind of
[Music]
you get used to living on the street yes
maybe you used to uh
what's the hardest thing about living
this kind of life
um
[Music]
you get depressed sometimes yeah
i do worry about the civil rights
you know justin i'm having a real hard
time understanding you
i can't really use a lot of resources
like that you know process of using that
let me get out of the streets the only
time i go about
and i'm just now you know what i'm
thinking i'm serious you know
you can't impress about how much i'm
procrastinating this is what happens
with my problems
do you have any friends i got
acquainted with everyone like myself
i've had friends
not a long time with these
holy 47 47
what was the best time of your
don't know how to life on that one okay
okay
you can let me know do you uh did you
have dreams
of doing anything with your life when
you were young
uh no not really
no you're always just surviving it
sounds like yeah
what's been the roughest time of your
[Music]
life
i just drug addiction once you're clean
that was from crystal meth or something
else
cocaine cocaine
and the drugs are alcohol i was
like i was going to be honest with you
i'm sorry i was like regardless
i'm sorry i have a hard time i was
drinking regular drugs
do you think the do you find the drugs
and alcohol help you
cope with some of the things you've gone
through in your life
yeah right it's out of place but yeah
i'm sorry i don't know if i didn't throw
me further out a lot of [ __ ]
oh you getting too old for it yeah
it's like a time where the tires pass
right and looking back at your life what
do you
what do you do you have any regrets
not really
do you do you feel like not having
parents
was the biggest factor in where your
life has ended up
uh
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
can't trust everybody
you still have hope of improving your
life or getting
getting things together
yes i'm trying to do that right you know
when i was out of
camera health and places like that
a this was other things
housing would be great for you right yes
do you ever feel that life is unfair
anybody wants to make me as soon as it
can be unfair
i'm sorry i can't seem unfair but i just
really want to make it
what do you worry about
well
i'm sorry can you let me ask you that
again i actually homie's
badges now this is crazy
i don't know that's just really bad for
my own place
i mean i guess a program or something
like that
very beautiful all right justin
thank you so much for sharing your story
and i wish you the best of luck out
there
okay i'll make your day a little bit
easier here with some money
thank you very much
you